were so full podcast welcome to the were
so full podcast for another week of
Rodrigo Torres Yemen and Felipe Esparza
doing our thing what we do every week we
get here and we just talk about stuff
that happens last night though we had an
awesome night Tuesday night I don't know
it wasn't agreed last night but Tuesday
night I had a show at The Comedy Store
it was sponsored by donuts and speedy
weed calm or speed weed don't calm what
is it
speed weed speed weed delivery calm yeah
man delivery services and they give us a
care package
oh man a lot of stuff in there man I buy
5 vape pens edibles did you open your
package already nah dude I just open up
the package and eat the donut yeah you
know the Box there's an ashtray and
they're like a metal ashtray it's made
it's like a metal ashtray in there and
they come with a little package of five
pre rose I seen the pre whirls yeah I
got like I don't know many three
packages of pre rose oh yeah still
wonder how good they are
indica oh [ __ ] I always feel like
sometimes man they went like some of
these three rows are way they went way
out on the packaging yeah like like how
about this man forget about the
packaging you know that fast is to make
sure the quality is good oh hell yeah
dude
when the package is better than the weed
yeah Mike came with a rose yeah but the
wheat a like dirt damn but it was all
good right oh yeah dude yeah man it was
like the guy gave me like 2010 I'm
exaggerating 10 joints to pass out
during those three my set and I'll have
a such a great state I forgot just
smoked Devon yeah man it was like the
first time like we had enough joy to
pass one out to everybody
hell yeah here you take one hell yeah
head up did you get lit up or what yeah
hell yeah I got disowned whatever oh my
leg
drop dead you know like drop there like
I'm Joey COGO or lee-sia I was at a good
level where I could talk concentrate and
maybe drive like a sativa high it were
very sativa but the vapor is not very
classy yeah I haven't even hit him yet
though they look bomb though I'm glad I
get you got a box shout out to Russell
Peters
yeah they don't give team and I was like
what hell yeah that full from speed we
was looking at me like why he holding
that box set out to a roots of the game
yeah man those bad ass shirts didn't
Reno teacher with him what happened oh
that give me that when you're wearing in
that dude his name's Gina right for
Speed Week Gino shut up did you know he
might be on a podcast in January first
time I heard of him what because I'm
first order is to get the step deliver
from him when he first started smoking
yeah also a mom a big thank you to Sam
Tripoli for hooking up that show comedy
chaos yes
the show was packed over the comedian
named Abby Allen Eleanor Kerrigan a
little Carrigan Brendan Schaub Chris
D'Elia Bryan Callen Joe Rogan finesse
Mitchell showed up at the end Russell
Peters Russell Peters bro and you Doug
and me doc Oh busted out nineteen oh
yeah it was a good I showed up it was
good man and it's time for some some guy
just Nick Gambrell but lying the linger
I think if you could allow your ass all
the way here man you want it but make
hurry back that would be a dig but I do
there was something smelly about that
fool but I want to say nothing me too
man but I didn't wanna be the [ __ ] the
bearer of bad news he showed up but I
was like he kept asking right I won't do
the podcast but who are you
well you ought to his page
it was nothing funny man nothing amazing
and he didn't really work for the radio
station he was doing he was claiming
he's an intern intern a liaison he's
doing college you want to blow up are
that easier go to be an architect I
drunkard answer oh my
anyways man upcoming shows this weekend
I'm gonna be at the Ontario improv
sold-out other shows are sold out but
next week December 8th are being Salinas
at the Fox Theater with Marcel argüello
Rodrigo Taurus December 9th Bakersfield
at the party really 742 at 17 and it's
an improv in and it's in Texas in
January I'm coming to Boulder Colorado
Portland Oregon's Chicago Illinois New
York New York Palm Springs Coachella
California that spotlight 29 choosing
Arizona casino check out our Phillipos
worldcom tour for all show dates and
taking links at philippi WorldCom shout
outs to itunes reviewers Glen from
Hacienda Heights Shamu 8:1 to tack and
violin see Kai am Starsky 11 dan one
Anthony granny from Louisiana who dad el
Buffalo Aaron's Lobo checker
slow be the wolf of 83 Paulie
Matt from the hat store in San Francisco
what's up party Mac I just met this guy
one time with wife at a store EP Moreno
who says leave the wife at home
sorry Lisa a competition man like 40 man
one time I posted a photo of lease at
night and some guy wrote some nasty-ass
[ __ ] bro what do you write he said damn
beat that [ __ ] up beat it up went home
sad marks honoree wanna stay right there
we're on the bottom bun we're looking oh
we're looking for a few experienced web
designers to overhaul our website email
at fans at Felipe's WorldCom for more
Intel Alisa
we want to overhaul our website and we
want experience I don't want any newbies
so an experienced web designers it's not
like a freebie job will pay and
everything but I'm looking for somebody
yeah man if your drawings are in crayon
don't hit about man this isn't for the
logo we might have a logo contest oh
this is for the website redesign oh okay
we do that website manners first because
we have a lot of artists at listenings
if you just start making memes last year
don't hit us up I want a web designer to
hit me up and let's talk also December
first the vinyl and digital of my help
of the comedy special comes out you can
listen to an iTunes Android phones
Spotify the dark web wherever you can
find a man and we have a vinyl for it -
it'll be a collector's item and it's a
real vinyl - I'm it's a pop-up video in
there did your toe and kind of poster on
a poster in double vinyl album double
vinyl here it is an hour long and it's
it also has a download card so you can
get the digital as well and it has a
poster and there are only 500 and
they're numbered and 180 grand final yes
there's a nice nicer you're the hard
bottom either one you can break on
someone's hand any shatters war zone
full podcast so last night man were at
the comedy store I don't really go out
too much because every time I go out man
people give me oh yeah man and I'm gonna
live right man and a live driver could
smell everything bro he was like man so
you for soon as I got I live right that
fool said I was cool you hook up you
hold me out there he was like driver
blew his hand out boy he could tell bro
that he was like yeah that's cool man
yeah man speed weed calm he hooked it up
oh yeah man they Irene is that we know
Jeannot Jeannot the casino
that'll be confuse genome Michelini from
95.7 calories Dan what to the roast
squab
oh yeah that's way old-school so man
what's up bro
chillin don't just got back from Midland
hell yeah brother it's me shout out to
him and the weather big hard man of
Thanksgiving was sad you know for people
like me who are over 265 man it was the
first [ __ ] things gave us to wear a
t-shirt bro who I really it was
Thanksgiving a little like a barbecue at
my house cuz I'm used to the I'm used to
like showing up bro the guy with a
picking sweater bro
layered layer bro looking thin with my
little eggnog you can be cool t-shirt on
Thanksgiving with the stain on it worse
Oh does that mean with my hair popping
that frequency what's up well we have a
guest with things oh yeah a legend all
the way from busy Bronx right Michael
Blackson here just came back for big
kidnap moussaka who got kidnapped bro
yeah man by Tyree Tyrese look at a fake
to me man more do you want from me do
you know that photos dude how do you
make like seven faster the furies and
still be behind at our support dog papi
too many bottles dog I don't know man
you know what you probably like he was
like me bro like I didn't pay child
support ever right but I was hoping for
that big painted and show up then
everybody gets paid and you know when I
want let's comment and it had no choice
they made me pay damn fool was like it's
funny like when when like serious people
know you have cash like the people who
actually warning not the people they
were on the street - yo $200 - Nicole
[ __ ] so they were happy for I'm
talking about like people like in
government they know you have the money
ran because I when I was collecting
unemployment I still had a job and they
wanted their 1700 bucks
double-dipping Montgomery Ward wanted
their money for that cheap-ass oven and
they're paid for god damn but I'm open
for $185 bro what it turned out to be at
the final price for I ended up settling
that bill when I was when he won I
cleared out all his debts and I wound up
settling that bill for $300 and it was
all those years later but you owed like
six and I talking about a house yeah
from from New York party waterboy how
would the obviously then spender call it
Casa de esta La Casa de fuerza like
answer a port-o-potty other state you
conics
was so fool chris reeve couldn't play
mess up what's up speaking of just
wearing a t-shirt bro I remember man I
did a show with kid Edwards on one and
it was ex crazy chick and in Seattle bro
a University of Washington oh wow and
roll it was 66 degrees dog almost 59 and
kid with where the [ __ ] is silk t-shirt
but only with a gold chain and he wasn't
even [ __ ] cold man on the road um you
know I said New York sometimes you know
but now I'm totally [ __ ] now it goes
below 75 I'm acting like a [ __ ] so uh
yeah I forgot about that show that's
good but we did we did lots of shows
together oh my goodness with fly yeah
with this show as Chris way where we
don't know what we were doing comedies
but we're performing on stage and the
whole time it is hard to be funny
because you keeping an eye on a promoter
make sure so true that's so true
can you work with me great easy I you
that or or Rick Martinez wait where's
Rick
let's break out pull out the old one
nice party man how you pick that guy out
because every let every promoter that
promote stuff like that goes to those
small shows with the Latino black or
white guy they got that warm black
comedian that the only book I know
lowball him all the time yeah like you
were him and Bastian is Shang bro okay
matches that you know we booked Shang I
don't know what is probably get somebody
low balling here bro yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah everybody Lam promoters they always
had their go-to Negro the promoter his
go-to was Jay Lamont all the time am i
right he will show up where it closed at
out and yeah oh yeah you don't want to
go in after Jay Lamont
oh no cuz it's like going on after
concert you know I'm saying yeah yeah we
like open for him you know so the band
comes on you know what I'm saying oh
yeah no no you never had to worry about
like I like a Rudy Moreno you never had
to watch him know that that's that
money's talked to his Bandys we go
nowhere but Rick Rick sometimes you got
to keep your eye on little slippery
riku cheering man that fool started Rick
Martinez though he responsible for story
nam free Latino shows in San Jose like
he's like yeah at the Emperor we got
burned out in now lately he took it to
San Jose he was like the first one and
then I was there he started other Rick
Martinez is like sean tizzle brother
will hook it up bro disciple pay me cash
then other southern I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm at the club and that was extra
bonus I didn't get the these girls
changed up the comedy show is to like
greet a meeting greet at another club oh
yeah yeah he's a hustler dawg give him
that he's a hustler and those I remember
some of those shows that that that
particular improv in San Jose
all the way up to the top you know yeah
Edwin was doing some of those too yeah
when he was doing
Asian nights yeah yeah I was the goat I
was the go-to Negro for the Asian shows
how long man like you were doing
everything we're gonna tell you what I'm
doing uh you know well you know son said
when I when I first started you know you
know you know comedy you know what it
was about 99 or 2000 and I had just got
fired from this TV show hosting a
syndicated show called your big break
and I was like man you know kidding play
was kind of in in a valley at the time
and I was like what am what am i doing
like whatever I want to do and it was uh
it was guys like Tommy Davidson and Bill
Maher that suggested that I started
doing stand-up and they kind of kind of
pushed me into it
and Oprah Winfrey was doing a TV show at
the time called funny people and who
they think are funny so a deal hugely
brought on some more Jon Stewart brought
on Louis black and Bill brought me on
and I was the first one of the first
times I did stand-up was on the on the
Oprah Winfrey Show and he'd go he's one
of the funniest guys I know he said I
feel the same way about about kid as I
feel about Chris Rock and I'm like what
are you talking about you know he was
saying stuff you never said to me
personally but you know it was away from
me
like to get back on stage and once once
I started doing it I was like yeah
listen feels really familiar you know
like being a rapper really helped
prepare me for being a comedian so at
the outset I was just trying to do as
much time as possible so I'm making
deals with Hartman at all the The Improv
you know I mean for some sick price like
gave him gave him a number you couldn't
turn down and I was doing all the Latin
stuff man I'm doing I'm stuff without
tortillas with uh without what you call
it with Willie yeah you know I'm doing
tortillas in with Willie Barcena walk
you know and I had and I had some Latin
material too so that you know that kind
of helped and you know Latin audiences
they they did when you you know when you
can dabble into into their world so I'm
doing that I'm doing Sebastian shows I'm
doing a root of already Rudy morena was
always great to me just starting out you
know all that not just the ice house but
the Commerce Casino and all the mother
spots
Sebastian was great you know Ric was
which was great we're gave me a lot of
stage time and in addition to all the
you know the other black and white
joints I was doing so
don't forget a top don't forget about
time of tea brother yeah you know even
you know haha was was cool you know I
mean never never really been much of a
Comedy Store dude or more of like a
Laugh Factory improv kind of dude but
you're not it it sometimes you sometimes
you feel comfortable in certain spots
and other ones you just like yeah it
just doesn't do it for me you know I
like going to see other people that
Comedy Store and now I hear it's back
hot again cuz it was it was it was kind
of dried for a minute yeah I was like
yeah I heard it's crack in there now I'm
so all the big names are coming back and
on Sam Tripoli had the night there well
the night they're armed
Skylar stones better stole my jacket out
man yeah I heard and I was like we go to
the shows and you look at the lineup and
you know I'm like wow man this is like
the lineup that would perform at the
Laugh Factory at midnight yeah yeah now
we're at prime time on toothache yeah
yeah yeah I was Chris D'Elia Joe Rogan
wow I can't believe I'm gonna stage bro
yeah yeah I heard these I heard they
like switched up management or something
like that they doing something because
for a while the big names wasn't coming
there no they got rid of Tommy we got
rid of Tommy who's Tom Tommy was like
the Booker they do the show forever
he together he's to imitate Mitzi shore
and ban you well he will always go with
me like if I was show up he'll put me up
but maybe because I didn't hang around
that long to get on his nerves you
weren't part of the politics I was a
part of the polity I just show up do
much to my show get free we for somebody
leave right it was just you can stop and
go you know just pick up and bounce yeah
but no I need to I need to come back
down through there man if it's if it's
cracking like that it is man we're not
well they hurt you for you to make the
transition from being this big-time
rapper and movie star to go to stand-up
comedy because technicality matters it's
like it's not like like gonna go from
going from being rich and famous to go
back to rich and famous and then you
guys start all over again I'm wears nope
yeah well mom yeah well you know like I
said I really found out that that my my
rap career had had really prepared me I
mean look that's how that's how I came
up in the rap game you know we didn't
start in stadiums and arenas you know we
started in the clubs
Katz was right in front of us so like I
said he brought me kind of back to that
and I found out that I really really
enjoyed it and it's it's it's it's it
was similar but there's different
muscles you know it's it's it's not me
in a group anymore it's just me by
myself and so you know and and it was
fun trying to find what your identity
was you can you can meet a guy to get it
identity I remember you you and I talked
and you were telling about this sure you
did like in New York and they were like
I'm I don't know what what time it was
in your career but you said that I'm
everybody they were asleep
whether they were there to see this guy
from OPP uh-huh no D buddies yeah yeah
we're in the same show oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean we still look we play and
I've been on this I love the 90s tour
almost like the last two years so that's
that's groups like salt and pepper
Naughty by Nature of vanilla ice for our
base tone low Coolio yeah matter of fact
matter of fact in January they have this
they have this huge cruise ship tour
that we're doing it's called ship hop
and although all the groups are I'm not
even [ __ ] look it up ship hi
everybody
yeah yeah it goes out from our January
11 to the 15th out of out of Miami so
also all the groups that have been on
the Isle of the 90s tour will be on or
hanging out and performing for the year
for the four days the Bahamas are some
yeah I think there's a couple of stops
I forgot I think um I forgot what the
two stops are but I never get off the
boat anyway how does that work do you
hide from the people on the cruise the
rest of the week like how long cuz
they're gonna be wanting yeah I mean
what I think what they try to do on
cruises like that and I've been on other
cruises where where we perform obviously
you have the performances but usually
what they'll do is they'll schedule like
meet and greets during the day and you
know there'll be a whole line of the
entertainers and people coming up
getting pictures and autographs and
what-have-you um you know what the the
they try to try to train the passengers
like you know you got to take pictures
you know I mean you got to take pictures
you know I mean look the fans are paying
top dollar
you know these cruises ain't cheap so um
you know I think the the celebrities
that stress out about that or you know
I'm not really done with that I mean I
appreciate the fans
and the fans that are still been
sticking with us for the last 25 30
years you know what I mean the least you
can do is take a picture so I'm kind of
cool with that other celebrities you
know not so much so yeah they'll be kind
of high now but that's one of the
reasons why sometimes when the boat
docks a lot of the celebrities don't go
get off the ship because then everyone
else goes off and do their thing we all
go up to the top deck and it's just kind
of us so we got like about 3-4 hours to
ourselves so you know you pick your
spots it's fun ship hop come on Felipe
ship huh take your lady rock the boat
thank you take your lady and beat that
up on the boat ship hobro ship out
that's gonna be saying that all day bye
bye kiss army yeah it's the same concept
so and you know these promoters are just
like well why not why not why not I mean
the two like I said it's been going on
the last two years we've been doing like
really sick numbers you know what I'm
saying you know 8,000 here 14,000 there
we're going on Montana South Dakota all
over the place so uh you know and it's
nice seeing the old hip hop heads and
fans come out you know unfortunately
sometimes particularly the ladies try to
wear the old outfits from back in the
days but they don't quite fit anymore
overlap yeah those jeans with the cuts
in them it's not looking right there's
an extra meet coming out looking like a
honey baked ham a couple of do short
wear showed up with biker shorts
yeah biker shorts spandex you know that
dressing up like salt and pepper and all
year with broke chains and I enter
Vanilla Ice pants look like Salton Sea
yeah yeah guys guys coming in with wigs
like my old high-top fade they do the
most but it's fun it's fun we're looking
forward I would feel good you know like
two people to show up dressed like you
yeah it's it's it's it's you know it's
been real cool these these fans in
particular look and a lot of these a lot
of these fans you know come to the the
stand-up shows as well you know they'll
come to my stand-up shows with you know
with old wino
yeah with North all the time yeah I saw
how we're doing the show that Latino
guys showed up with a house party movie
and it was bootleg yeah all three house
party bootleg boot like I'm like really
come on man really bad house party and
Friday we're in the same video
you don't yeah exactly I say and you
don't spell house party it's not it's
not two E's at the end okay it's a why
okay so that should let you know whose
it was bootleg one of the funny business
I heard you say was when you said it we
were see you at a motel room somewhere
and your movie house party was playing
in Spanish that's right like it was
weird
no yeah it was weird cuz I was getting
high at the time and I was like yeah
buddy no I do that what's bad but ya
know I've seen I've seen my movies in
Spanish I mean look III movies you been
in G's we did three house parties we did
we did a cameo in a fifth house party
that they did we did the movie class act
class yeah then then did a few a bunch
of a bunch of TV movies as well and what
they're talking about doing now is over
at that network TV one they're trying to
do like a kid and play biopic like you
know like have people play us as we were
growing up Connacht act like the new
addition one that they did so you know
we're trying to you trying to work that
out and figure out what's going on who
will play you I don't know it's a good
question they'll find some white kid
[Laughter]
Matt Lauer he needs a job 20 20 million
a year he's starving a man you saw yes
but he can't come out so waited for some
harassment to come out of beat he got it
he got it I know I was a little
surprising
I don't harass you right they pay low
they tell you low BP let's that's their
um that's their kind of a tradition you
know I'm saying but have you done BET's
comicview no you know what Jeff no no I
mean to be honest I mean Def Jam the
heyday of Def Jam was before I became a
stand-up and and a comic comic view as
well you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
not not too many of those not too many
of those but I remember I remember when
you were doing um
Last Comic Standing any time you saw
somebody that was that you knew yeah and
that you knew was funny it was like you
know man we just root for the
do like every week like come on man come
on yeah get him get him
Thank You Man and then I used to run
into you at the Dodger games
oh yeah well blue yeah you must have
been deep this year were you geek and
then you got then then it hurt at the
end
yeah man game fire and never forget my
other longest game yeah man they were
tied the Dodgers came back did you go
did you go to any of the game I need the
World Series
yes I went to Game five Game six came
one pan and safe with my wife and um
Game five I went with Paul Jordan apes'
I was doing a military gig with finesse
Mitchell and then I he flew and if we
can fly me out fly yourself out
that's why and then we said behind the
Dodger dugout oh so like this close to
coach a good job good job
right but you were there the last night
he was in the night - no no no okay okay
game six that's it okay do you think
that guy proposing to his girlfriend
understand it was like a sign of
disrespect to the stadium your mom
thought it was she was pissed
my mom was peers Wow somebody proposed
yeah was that bad lower Lander Verlander
promotes oh okay
so Kate Upton oh yeah yeah yeah the
Latin guy yeah okay he was doing the
most right I was like yeah he's gonna
get blown tonight that's for sure yeah
man every day somebody's gonna get this
salad toss tonight yes my mother
disrespect they proposed to her at
Dodger Stadium he could have wish we got
home oh yeah well he was no thunder in
Houston yeah he's looking for the
biggest stage you know what I'm saying
yeah he sorry for something man I just
came back from I just came back from
using I was doing some comedy uh in
Houston at this black Club and they're
still the name of it she is called the
Ultra Lounge or salon
Ultra ultra lounge but yeah that still
geek down there man I need anybody that
mentioned anything anybody that
mentioned the Astros on stage the crowd
to a Josh Reddick bro but a Lamborghini
are you serious damn John's ready for
the Astros he he came to my show of The
Improv but
a lot I hate coming from the fans bro
yeah we do [ __ ] cuz he would like do
that for ya yeah yeah the terrible city
yeah yeah I mean consump you can they
say like you know what I don't think
you're gonna get a ring you know Kenny
you know what I'm saying like you didn't
and like sorry but we'll give it nobody
started they did that how you didn't do
so other words so we're gonna give you a
ring but there'll be no stones on it
yeah right
it just says champ gets the promise ring
is there for moral support
it's a promise it was like when you it
would let you know now all the kids got
the best high school ring you know I
didn't get one
no did you get one Lisa in a classroom a
classroom yeah but not everybody had the
Justin [ __ ] ring so but um but see
like if you're like a rich kid you're
gonna have the best class ring right if
you're a poor kid you're gonna have a
ribbon right you're gonna get the
Lamborghini of rings so you grew up in
New York man I did only like hip-hop um
yeah but but I'm old enough to remember
when there wasn't hip-hop you know what
I'm saying like I'm an old G like that
you know and I can remember I was war uh
I said it Hey
yeah yeah I mean that old-school
underground yeah I mean I started
rhyming um when I was like when I was a
freshman in high school and that was
like two three years before rappers
delight
you know what I mean we didn't there
wasn't there wasn't any rap records out
until like you know 80 80 just blondie
he came out with her exactly exactly and
and the hip-hop heads was like are you
serious yes like connection like white
people King came we have this yes can we
have this but you know actually that
Network it did a lot it did a lot to
help and and she did it as a you know
Maj you know she was into the downtown
scene the hip-hop scene so she was
actually promoting it you know oh by the
way before I forget I wanted uh chil
know I brought my I brought one of my
kids here with me my daughter of
Christina hello he's visiting from from
New York for the week so I thought I'd
bring her daughter yeah it's my daughter
she uh she she lives in works in New
York's works for Nickelodeon she works
to poison the minds of young children
[Applause]
and a mother a mother Dominicans we
should get that charge the very next
rate here took me nine hours I remember
I I hosted a wedding show in New York
Dominican family and a Puerto Rican
family blended blended Rome New York
look here man and then um I remember
like um I had to roast them at the end
of the show
mm-hmm could I get you know I got to
know the whole family and then I got to
know deep deep thoughts about him it was
crazy man like and so he was pulling the
cord Porto Rican wine bro in more
cleavage at the wedding yeah more
cleavage
instead of church yeah yeah I would like
to choose Christ no doubt the Dominicans
will probably have more more more booty
though yeah I'm seeing this and better
here tremendo culo
tremendo culo what's up my [ __ ] what
you got going right Stone Rodriguez Lee
what I heard you say using Jews just in
Midland yeah Midland Odessa don't that
clear right Wawa's no I think I I think
I did but like a really really long time
ago I haven't been there and been there
in a while but I've done I've done all
I've done those you know those border
spots like you know what's a San Angelo
or you know like the head like all those
streets that look like No Country for
Old Men
yeah McAllen McAllen Academy was Super
Mario right I remember McAllen
Brownsville all that stuff man like I've
you know I've I've done my time but how
was it used it was hot no it was cold
actually oh well we let you say that you
bet
well the lesson you went to Midland
Odessa it's probably been like maybe I
don't know at least 3-4 years maybe
wow man well what the play that we stood
at would would like one hotel room and
there was more hotel rooms lately it's
changed they got more hotel rooms really
before it was just small right I'll
notice how now man it's it's moving up
let's look at that they got all that oil
money next okay they got more oil money
but you know what over there you know
like in here in that California you know
we were more liberal we talked about how
the gas companies you know that they're
polluting the air the dirty oil over
there man now they don't even mention
oil didn't even call it gas well they
call it illegal energy corporations yeah
energy company yeah that sounds nice the
Chevron energy company we provide energy
and power to all United States of
America okay clean air bro right there
are no smog checks in Texas
yeah here are now labor oh you hit a
[ __ ] good you can even grab your own
corporal got a guy that sells meth he
causes of Energy Corporation and
providing energy oh yeah what you been
up to man I heard you gotta you gotta
you got your oh I started following you
because you have your own brand of
marijuana that's right it relays Katy
blaze is the company that's kind of the
movement you know we got we'll get you
some we'll get you some swag
yeah kidding kidding blaze is kind of
like the movement which which kind of
incorporates the the weed you know music
merchandise there's also a part of the
the company that we're dedicating just
to the the medicinal aspects of it like
just the CBDs you know so that we can
work with hospitals that are treating
people with seizures we call that Park
hidden cure but the first strain is
called our kitten cookies which is a
nice hybrid joint that will knock your
dick in the dirt okay
yes that's off that's our mouth that's
our motto with the company eating
cookies it'll knock your dick in the
dirt CBD CBD there was a vape pen in
that bars or CBD and I got to explain to
me but it has no THC it won't get your
mind high but I'll get your body high so
can rest yeah yeah aches and good you
know great with aches and pains and
stuff like that they've taken up way
Luna I don't think it's even like that
it's like what they give kids like if
they have seizures and stuff that gets
him high they're giving him and the
strain that has benefits better dribbler
strongly up strictly medicinal
yeah there's no high side effect I guess
you could call it yeah anybody want to
try though
the way it's extracted
anybody want to say the CBD vaping for
an actual joint you should try it try it
try try try just to see biddies and ends
and see how you feel that's what's in
your lotion that you had worked on your
name that's a tiny that stuff is dude
I've met some really high but when I
wrote the dog it did feel hot right away
my knee got high yeah money got high you
were somebody new that day had a Jordan
face kid off the feet get off the field
you're fired
yo um yeah it's funny you should mention
that cause um you know I was I was
skeptical like a couple years back with
the you know with the lotions and what
this and and I we were out on this dis
just kidding plate or I was telling you
about and I kind of twisted my knee on
stage one night and then in addition to
that you know my feet were kind of
bothering me too
I used to have to ice the knee before
the show I said afterwards it was real
real [ __ ] up so I was kind of at my
wit's end I was just like man you know
what let me try this Queen you know what
if I have to lose so I'm rubbing on my
knees and on my feet and man listen that
thing was I'm jumping around like the
Nicholas brothers and [ __ ] you know I'm
pop locking and you know I'm doing it
was so I swear by it now you know and
and you know my knee hasn't hurt since
it did it just doesn't the swelling went
down and and you just rub it in on the
top you ain't doing nothing you know you
don't do nothing more than that so I'm
able Eve it works I believe it is it a
solver or lotion of the lotion that's a
lotion there's one that's like a little
more like like like a little greasy of
it but they all work man yeah they work
it work man I just need it more yeah
yeah get you some more that stuff boss
that stuff is I said it was like I had a
little little I hit a frozen case like a
no refrigerator inside and it was in
there yeah what about what about edibles
you mess with edible hell yeah yes see I
don't they creep me out I get one for
this Mitch almost cured oh oh really
they keep the whole thing yeah he did
they creep me out because I like it
fills now I need to read now I wanted to
the edible I read the label to Gossage
how long it takes before I could eat
another one
keep eating them so now they stay 75
minutes I wait and man yeah but you got
a look at the you got a look at the
because some of these I got ya I got
different dosages man big-ass cookies
and stuff you know once once a in 50 or
75 and another one saying like 200 so
you know you got a you got to do it
accordingly man you know that'll but
I've always I've always had a bad
experience with the edibles so I don't
even mess with that stuff you ever had a
real bad experience on edible you said
that what the hell where did I take this
I did I did um years ago Bill marvel
I'll call me up he said he had gotten
some some cookies from from a guy that
we know so he said I'm here i'ma try my
lie let you know what you know what's up
I said fine I get up he left a message
on my answering machine like two o'clock
in the morning he was like hey it's bill
this isn't good like he was petrified
right so my dude so I spoke to him the
next day I was like you know man what
happens oh it was just a bad trip in and
I just couldn't I couldn't I just had to
wait for it to wear off there's nothing
I could do
he says hey man you can take these
cookies of you you want them you can
have them
and like I [ __ ] I took the cookies
and I took him with me to New York so I
go to New York I was doing some morning
radio and I'm in this hotel in the city
and I figured yeah you know what I'm
getting ready to go somewhere let me try
one of these cookies and they would they
were delicious like they were delicious
you couldn't even taste the the weed or
anything but I started to feel funny and
so I got downstairs and I'm trying and
I'm trying to leave the hotel I got
somewhere to go and I just can't leave
the hotel like I just won't I'm scared
to leave like the doors keep opening and
closing then opening and closing opening
calling finally I just went upstairs
locked all the doors and just got into
the covers and just had wait waiting for
it to just subside but it was just as
bad as bills was but that's my fault
like you know if the do tow you had a
bad trip or something what you doing
eating it you know well I want to get
him saying I was double chocking man
yeah I guess so maybe I mean I was
thinking it was gonna work on me but but
it worked just as much or more so that
taught me a lot about the edible saw ice
tea
clear that you will a car there I'm a
smoker I'm a smoker if you were like
that ok I do [ __ ]
yes exactly week yeah yeah meanwhile I
can't leave I can't leave the building
you know I'm saying and there's nothing
stopping me but me so I pay more close
attention now I like to be like that in
the inner blinker then I just pass out
oh yeah I know what he's feeling the way
you were feeling Chris you just want to
get a little bar in the black man your
head is in you're thinking about stuff
you know all your regrets in life Chris
that's how I feel I feel like if I do
that on the plane I'm gonna be thinking
about what how we're gonna go down right
you're gonna you're gonna make a move
for the cockpit but then like my body
feels like I'm starting menopause you
only got a few more days
[Laughter]
how the power to menopause
I watched the Baywatch movie 5 the rock
is amazing can he do 5,000 face with v1
I'm boo - what more do you want from me
it's everybody differently man yo did
you hear they made a record out of that
you know these hip hop dudes
they always gonna make a beat out of
something so they made a beat out of
when Theresa was was getting all
emotional and stuff yeah yeah - you it's
terrible what's it called that's the
worst man like gonna cry cry cry start
out cry man it's the beginning credit
kills them and here buddy laughing
like if you like dogs need to cry man
you just want a thug holding bag it's
just I'm sad like I was supposed to pay
for Charles [ __ ]
nobody pay for mine no your daughter
does job is to put people away alright I
told my dad that how much I owed and you
know and I tell my daughter like all
that's [ __ ] up yo that much you know
you're a piece of [ __ ] father instead of
saying that to me like you're a horrible
father my destiny is nothing my neighbor
he owes 200,000 his kids are 30 we're
back with interest
yeah we got to pay for the cadet
programs where they jumping on the on
the girls and driving the police cars
and stuff man the penalty money goes to
the mom no yeah man and in California
you accrue penalties even if the kids
over 18 if you are if you are in arrears
if you like if you owe $7,900 by the end
of the year you don't know that you know
that just that one payment it's gonna go
to maybe fourteen thousand two hundred
eighty doubles that's just one month you
know no way you know how you know way
too much about that you got the
calculation how I won that one I keep
telling people man pay them reader paste
something man they even if you can't
afford what the Italian man
I couldn't afford to pay 80 bucks a
month the gym wants you to pay something
somethings better than nothing
what do you almost I don't know [ __ ] not
yet well sad is those dudes that get
caught up when I go tell them I'm
pregnant and later on and never was kid
oh yeah that happened that happened to
me but don't you sign what happened that
was me way back in the days there was
his girl I used to date I was still I
was in New York this girl was out of DC
so a chick I used to date out of DC and
you know she boss up when labels like
y'all are you know I'm pregnant or
whatever and so I'm counting back you
know I'm saying and and the numbers
don't add up you know I mean the months
don't add up it was like 11 months I
said what you carry this baby for 11
[ __ ] months like baby wasn't that I
had a kid kid yeah exactly
um so I was like I bet I said let's take
a let's take a paternity test you know
I'm saying that then back in the days
with what they used to do was you hook
it up through your lawyer they sing you
to this you know like outpatient clinic
and they draw your blood and they take a
back in it is that this long ago they
take a Polaroid picture of the guy
drawing the blood so that he knows your
blood and whatever like that then he
sent it to some lab like in North
Carolina and then they do the analysis
so I did mine and then I guess later in
the week she was supposed to do hers I
had set up for her in DC and everything
she never went she never went and never
took the test come to find out it was
the baby was she had a boyfriend some
dope dealer that died in a car crash
that's who the father was and she was
just trying to you know make a move you
know I mean but you know what you know
you tried you gave it a gave it a shot
but I'm like yo you what you carry this
baby for 11 months what what is that
that's that medically possible Lisa help
me out here no about 10 months 40 weeks
right this world is too crazy
no kid didn't want to come out and play
doctor hell no man that's crazy man a
woman doing that oh that [ __ ] happens
all the time right I mean I would
imagine
only time it happened to me you know
what I'm saying but I mean in our
industry you know what I'm saying I
would imagine that you know and and look
I got I already have two baby mamas and
you know I got I got I got lucky with
mine I mean they're great mothers and
you know I never I swear to God I never
had any doubt
for example that any you know any money
that was that was you know being sent I
had never had any doubt that it was
being used you know for for my children
you know I mean like you know I hear
horror stories you carnation [ __ ] you're
they getting yeah oh yeah give me that
and then and then when they bring your
kids around your kids are looking crazy
you kids ain't shine and you know any
time my kids Mother's brought the kids
around kids are looking right you know
what I mean all lysed up and hair done
and clothes looking right and stuff like
that so you know you gotta get you know
you got to get lucky with baby momma's
you know I got lucky with mine mine one
of Mines is I got a black one and I got
a Dominican one and I got and and I'm
done okay I got a condom on right now I
had one surgically and play don't play
I know me okay so yeah yeah yeah but yes
well I mean it's wild out there I mean
you know it did the little baby had a
little big hair too that would be a
telltale yeah man you know what that
thing that you know that the hair thing
is probably is gonna literally follow me
until the day I die and that not that I
mind I'm already envisioning it's go
yeah great and that that's that's cool
because it that kind of you know it
keeps it keeps us it keeps me you know
relevant in that regard because you know
I'm recognized as the guy with with the
hair but I'm already envisioning that
that my tombstone will be shaped like my
hair you know I'm envisioning that and
I'm also another thing I'm thinking
about too is you ever see like on the
Grammys on the Oscars when they go
through the in memoriam like the people
that have died the previous year I'm
thinking you know what I should start I
want to pick my picture now so that they
don't you use a [ __ ] up picture of me
you know what I'm saying I want to get
like
you know you know when I was at my
happiest I make a mug shot or some [ __ ]
like that
to put a mess up one huh you know think
you want to get a fly one line you don't
again will get a pop OH
oh that's apples not my finest hour now
that's what's good that's what's up so
what's up so you never had I'm better
than everyone you hear that high either
who my daughter yeah
oh no she's now she's wrong person she's
quite quite independent she goes she
graduated from college last year and she
worked like I said she works with
Nickelodeon and she's having a blast
she's a good kid
how did they approach you like when you
got your movie deals with a mood or 3d
or movie the urge no no no no another
success no what happened was I mean just
as kid and play we'd already you know
blowing up on the rapture - yeah we did
that's right cartoon cartoons and MC
Hammer had a cartoon - yeah we well yeah
I mean hammers is a good friend of ours
hammers was on ABC like the year after
our first rappers would Accord to me
that's what he was a good like he could
he could roast like roast people and
oyster oh yeah yeah yeah I mean we would
we've done dozens and dozens of shows
with each other over the years and
everybody you know all the tours were
great I mean I've toured with everybody
from Hammer so Fresh Prince I don't know
if you've got time I've done time I did
a show with them and in our San Diego
about six months ago believe it or not
if you guys seen the movie Straight
Outta Compton there that that concerts
were that they were on in 89 we were on
that tour kidding playin NWA dude go
figure
you killed it one of my best movie ever
saw well not my brother my nephew saw
that movie like 10 times in a row he's
like a little four-year-old kid but he
was he loves it when you play the guy
that I'm that has a the beat ups or a
record studio into the temptations oh
yeah yeah yeah
love that movie much yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah the deejay is that
mean yeah yeah the jockey the disc
jockey yeah yeah you know what that was
that was it like
that movie man that well it was great
you know my manager at the time Suzanne
the pebbles Suzanne to pass and she was
actually one of the producers on the
film so she was managing me at the time
and she was producing that film that
they were filming in Pittsburgh matter
of fact because Detroit didn't really
look like Detroit anymore but for some
reason parts of Pittsburgh kind of
looked like Detroit so that's where they
were filming so she just called me about
the blue she said hey I got a I got a
part for you though it's a one-day shoot
fly-in fly-out you know you get X amount
let's go men went in there I was in and
out you know but but um I'm you know I
feel I feel fortunate to be in that
movie for you know as little as it was I
mean it's one of the great you know
miniseries it's like one of them things
like if you flipping channels you're
gonna oh you're gonna watch that you're
gonna watch 20 minutes a half an hour
type house yeah type deal you know what
you know what scene it is you know
what's covered up next yeah yeah you
know check this out check this out this
is when this when David Ruffins in the
crack house yes like what time I watch
this temptation and they were they
stopped at that scene where David Ruffin
is arguing Marvin Gaye and
what's-her-name and then he's telling
penny and he's telling her
Tammy altimeter aliens he was man was
treated with respect he looks listen man
y'all don't know [ __ ] about me y'all his
mama boys yeah oh yeah no that's my boy
Leon that was playing on a david ruffin
he's great I love to have him in a
podcast oh man he's he's he's I mean
he's great actor you know intense you
know we should play a lot of basketball
together he can really play some
basketball too but yeah yeah he was that
was a great role for him great role for
him
yeah and they they still run that sucker
you know yeah I mean that's that's kind
of the cool thing about it man I mean
it's it I feel fortunate that you know
the movies that that we've done and
stuff like that you know the stuff still
holds up I mean they're not they're not
playing it because people don't like it
they plan it because you know people are
reminded that that error you know they
like all that they like that ninety
stuff you know that's when it feels like
life was simpler and you know even even
some of the young people like like my
daughter's age are really into that that
95 they like the colors they like the
dances they like the just the fun aspect
of it it just doesn't seem as drama
rific as as the landscape is today so um
you know it's cool I mean I was I was in
Atlanta hanging out with some folks that
we were hanging outside this barbecue
and this little girl little black girl
came up she's about six years old and
she saw she caught sight of me she said
oh she ran all the way over to me and
she pointed at me she said you got a
whoopin what you say you got a whoopin
I said who gave me a whoopin yo pops I
said how you know my pops gave me a
woman she said my auntie watched that
movie all the time she ain't got no job
robbing here yeah yeah yeah exactly
that's that she so so that's like I was
like how does a six-year-old know about
this stuff because that means that you
know auntie's is passing it down to the
to the kids you know Big Brother's
passing down the little brothers you
know families are watching it together
so the first ones a [ __ ] classics man
look the first one's a classic people
people love the movie classic I mean
over all those movies you know
represented a lot in terms of new talent
you know house party one you got Martin
you know you got full force you got but
you got a Robin Harris you know Bernie
Mac was first meet well was a house
party three TLC was in house party three
Queen Latifah was in house party
chuckling Chris Tucker for his first
movie was house party three uh he was he
came off him yeah he came off from he
yeah he was managing the managing
stripper he came off stage at the Comedy
Store one night I was hanging in the
back the director called me said yo man
we shooting the scene tomorrow we ain't
got nobody to play the character's name
was Johnny boobs he said we ain't got
nobody played Johnny booze so I say
y'all and I just seen Chris come
offstage and Krista just got to town and
you know he was lighting it up so I
stepped to him I'm a new Chris I was
like yo man yo you I said come on down
tomorrow man I just sent him down there
and he went down there and did a great
job and you know then of course you know
that makes me feel responsible told you
his entire career
oh that's Michael Collier his name was a
showboat so Bobo
oh yeah yeah oh so we have been
fortunate that we just had all these
great you know I mean kids play get a
lot of credit for it but there's a whole
lot of great people in these phones we
just ran into Angela
bye Felicia who knew her fiance he it
was my fiancee she was my fiancee I had
her first
[ __ ] also vegan yeah no I mean she was
my girl from my movie girlfriend just
like just like just like on the Martin
show teach the camera she was my girl
first yeah yeah my sloppy second as you
know means we saw her we were vegan
little spot
jackfruit cafe on Crenshaw yeah
jackfruit cafe on Crenshaw yeah my
design to go to Crenshaw p.m. soul food
beacon soul food realized very delicious
macaroni she works really hard
yeah I'm gonna give her a shout I think
she I think yeah I think we went back
and forth like on Twitter a little DM
action but yes she was great she won't
she won't great to work with
how funny wasn't working with how almost
did you laugh on the set working with
all those great comedian like Robert
Harris I was it was awesome you know
what I'm saying and Robin was like you
know Robin was older than us you know
yeah forty huh no he now he was only 36
he died at 36 oh um but he was old
enough we were all in like in our early
20s you know I'm saying so we all defer
to him and he was just a great dude he
took care of us he looked out for us you
know we all play basketball together be
him it be me be Martin Tommy Davidson
Tommy Ford and you know he kind of took
care of us I remember one time we had we
got into some beef with some some dudes
at the gym you guys talk you know guys
talking [ __ ] whatnot and Robin was like
I okay hello alright wait right there
goes out to the car comes back with the
pistol like he's got his gym shorts on
everything and he got the pistol by side
talking on now what now what a great so
I mean this guy is bringing a greater
kamini as he was like he still is like
yo uh-huh he still had that yeah that's
treated him you know but I tell you I'll
tell you a funny story they told me you
know we had a lot we had a lot of scenes
together so we had a lot of downtime so
you know who go back and forth and he
told me this story I don't know if it's
100% true or not but this is the story
you told me he said back in the days he
was dating this girl and she wanted him
to meet her parents so they were gonna
have him over for dinner so you know
Robins you know he's a little nervous or
whatever like that so they go over there
and
have dinner it's him the girl the mother
and the father so they have dinner
dinner goes well and then there's
dessert so they have some dessert the
mother made a pie so the pie comes out
and he eating the pie and then they get
down to one piece of pie left so the
father is like hey Robin man go on gonna
get that last piece of pie man gonna eat
that last piece of pie and he's like no
sir you know I'm fine man you know
dinner was great you're not gonna need
any more pie thank thank you though man
go ahead on man get that piece of pie
man it's delicious pie man mama made
this pie make it just no I'm cool man
will you go on and eat this pie and
don't insult us just go on eat that pie
and enjoy that pie and he's like okay
all right sir you know what I will eat
this pie so you ate the pie and so after
after dinner the mother and father's in
the kitchen washing dishes
Robin has to go to the bathroom let's go
to the bathroom you got a pass by the
kitchen so as he passing by the kitchen
he has the father say to the mother can
you believe that [ __ ] ate the last
piece of [ __ ] pie but that's you know
mean Bernie Mac was great on on take the
pen yeah Bernie Mac was great on said
you know Martin Martin's was was great
back then you know full force was always
pulling pranks on people and sticking
notes to the back of your you know your
jacket and giving fans your yeah and the
little kids were little kid represent
your immature IMX yeah that was good
times and like I said TLC was was in
house party three with us as well so
good times good times
yeah I mean we just been doing shows
with TLC as well TLC's backing on the
road with just the two chicks didn't get
the new girl on the P no no no no they
just is just to Eternia no I thought
that Josie hired a new girl though yeah
they tried that like several years ago
but they didn't really fly so they just
do it's just two of them now I mean they
have like like a bunch of you know
dancers and and and the band with him
and whatnot but yeah they were doing
some of these I love the 90s dates as
well
so we did we were down here at the Greek
a few months ago so yeah good times
you're friends with comedian from
Houston Texas right Miguel Miguel Miguel
Miguel I thought you know I know a lot
of your ex cop sounds familiar I mean I
got some other guys down in Houston that
I messed with you know why like Juan
Villarreal Billy Dee Washington really G
Washington laughter guy yeah yeah Billy
Hill and I we work together yeah that's
my boy okay because he was late he plays
the keyboard yes hear me now when I did
a show together in Aspen uh-huh with
with what ability with Shane and Kevin
Shea another person I forgot her name
but the guys who are booked the show it
wasn't David Brenner oh really
the late David Brenner and we have
another mutual friend um you know Paso
he said that um we went to his house
Gabriel se has a night Roderigo Torres
and we he made us takes Steve George
Steve George Steve George and he said
that the the barbecue sauce that he made
was your recipes abilities Billy
probably more Billy Dee's than any yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I got a
pencil that's when we used to play there
that comics gets me some white boy they
get more read yeah but together the X
karma Gatito we make dinner for us and
he was tell you that that was a sauce
was your sauce really yeah then probably
more Billy's in any touch ability one
time he said that one time mom you gotta
put a prank on this British comedian you
get put barbecue sauce at his boots no
we put we put up we put salsa because
because we're this is his club in
Columbia Missouri and they didn't really
have a green room the green room was
like where they kept all the the
ketchups and you know the condiments and
all this enero de shabu DejaVu exactly
like these are yeah yeah with the
upstairs yeah the club is downstairs and
the comedy the club Club right yeah so
so you know what I'm talking about you
know it's like a closet so Steve Hurst
is the is the English comedian right and
what you do at that time back then he
was doing a whole Austin Powers thing so
he would literally go in the thing and
and
put his Austin Powers outfit on and come
back out but when he did that he put he
put drew shoes on so he had these other
shoes and we had these big vats of salsa
you know that so one time we just you
know we just put gang of salsa in in
disguise in his shoes and stuff so he
comes back and you know he's not
thinking about nothing he just goes you
know he puts his shoes on and he goes he
says egad
they put cells in me boot yeah now Billy
these good people I got another homeboy
in El Paso Jorge Jimenez who's a real
funny dude but yeah man you know how it
is you meet some really in charge over
John Roman know that we're doing the
[ __ ] West Comedy Club and that's what
metal corpus somebody could somebody hit
me up about corpus like they got a date
some new club down there huh Mesquite
oh no that's a new new one there the
Mesquite yes somebody hit me no one cuz
I'm crazy times back in the dayz time in
the back of the mall dude and they kept
sending up all the shots I'm gonna get
outside of the mall yeah yeah yeah bad
all the way around the back like you go
outside that mall you look outside like
the set of Walking Dead dude yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that and that was the club
they would warn you beforehand they're
like yo they're gonna send you I'm gonna
send you shots of the whole night and if
you don't do them they're really gonna
get mad so we would do it like like the
first two shots is real and I'm then and
after that I'm like yo just just make it
water you know it's gonna kill me so
yeah we would go down there to Corpus
and perform and then go go down to the
Selena statue and take pictures by her
but yo you seen that statue my thing is
um oh the rest of the meat made her but
rips I was arrested there for harassing
a statue they got me for a statutory
around try the veal try the pickle juice
flavor snowcone the best we got corn
with mayonnaise here hey yeah but yeah
somebody yeah I wasn't aware like what
what the new club was I'm sure come true
a happy times this mesquite pizza and if
the guy
Aaron and it's booked by this fat-ass
fool named Wynonna pretty close big new
driving us a stomach oppressing the horn
the other one that John Roman used to
have was Gators Gabriel for like three
years or so went down there yeah but I
don't know we do the comments trip all
the time and then there me and me and
the owner got into it one time we had to
be separated he didn't want to give he
wanted to continue though the birthday
shows huh
and not honey no you know what he you
know what happened was I had I had to
leave I couldn't do a Sunday show
because I was ill I was I was starting I
was starting a TV show over at vh1 so
you know you know club owners kind of
know the rules if I mean if you got a
jet back to LA for for a job yes for
some TV you know that'll bring more
light than the next time you come that's
how it is so I had told him I was it's
not like I sprung it on my last minute
but he was never really that you know
happy about it or whatever so he had
been chirping at me all you know all
weekend long about this that and third
and finally he you know he got into it
again and he was then he's trying to say
something about you know about the you
know about the house you know like yo
you know I'm saying you know talking
about the numbers I said well hold up
boss I said when I came when I used to
come to town we used to do two TV
stations we should do radio how we do a
buzz you know and all that stuff I said
we don't hardly get there no more I said
I said how am I [ __ ] supposed to know
I'm here if we know if we don't tell him
I make I made myself available for that
you just hang got the juice so you're
trying to blame me cuz you ain't got the
juice and you're trying to build a you
trying to build a high-class restaurant
I don't know why he come in for that
[ __ ]
and he's a big right-wing or two so I
like none of that [ __ ] anyway you know
what I'm saying he's one of those make
America make America hate again yeah so
then yes so then he was like you know
I'm saying he says something and then
then he does then he like stood up we
were in his office he stood up on me I
say what so I stood up
now would and then his son and and I
think I think I didn't think Billy Dee
was there too late they bust in the room
and separated as I said man yeah so I
you know I left I didn't play the Sunday
show and then me and him probably didn't
speak for like bout six seven years you
know I'm saying but I was still coming
out of Paso doing other stuff you know
what I'm saying like I don't know I
don't need you to come never pass oh I
got friends here so then finally we
squashed it man you know he he kind of
semi reach it out and then I was like
you know what that stuff is in the past
man so one time we went what time we was
in El Paso we went by the club and on a
Tuesday night like like like an open mic
night and this dude is in he's in there
on the Tuesday night I'm rockin the
board I'm like dude you don't like your
wife at all dude like what you doing
here on a Tuesday night Tuesday Tuesday
no hardly nobody was there you know what
I'm saying lord knows what he's doing
but yeah that's all beef man you know
how it is but that's that's the thing I
mean somebody's somebody's club owners
we talked about promoter somebody club
almost the same way man they'll try to
shoot you if you let him you know all
the time but yeah my leg when I was you
would do when I was go to a pass it
would be buzzed all the time yeah
buzzers great and then after that you
sneak over there and do that fat guy mic
for kiss-fm right but their mic the last
time I would go there
Mike pulled me to the side from KISS FM
he goes man man y'all really get along
with that club one little more so but
this is you yeah after you're done with
buzz come on in
yeah yeah I wasn't there with the owner
I was there was that I'm Nico guy and
I'll show so they they let me they let
me do though they let me do the but the
kissing fan but and was in the pain it
wasn't paid you know I didn't want to
pay yeah yeah yeah but that's the thing
you can pay for TV club owners they'll
sometimes they'll take advantage they'll
take advantage of your fame yeah of your
fame of my fame and not pay rent or I'm
like dude you got it you got a yellow my
god you know what I'm saying like you
know I'm say I do shows up there was a
powder all the time I'm just like yeah I
get some people up there man so yeah II
take advantage of that and then they
know they know if you got kid you can
probably get on it pretty much any TV
show or we don't like you know good
morning El Paso or you know that type of
stuff that they would put me on the
hip-hop station too as well so you do
buzz and then run and run around and
take you to the hip-hop station you know
put that out there but yeah then he
start you start slacking you start
slacking man okay I can't do all the
heavy lifting I know man like some of
the old promoters that would they want a
book bring you back at the same rate and
you know you don't know how to tell them
listen man I'm grown yeah as a performer
and not my fault that you have now grown
as a promoter yeah you're still doing
$200 rooms
hey Tommy the price used to be here now
the price is here bro I mean come on my
lineage richer like the cherry
compliment you but their insult you but
I remember that you get you hear $400
Wow
so how'd you get your open for 200 now
they're like where is the loyalty but
you know it's their job to connect or to
little Twitter followers oh you got
thousands thousand followers on
Instagram robots oh yeah we were
watching this TV show last night my
daughter likes to watch this TV show on
Vice land called Jesus and marrow yeah
and they got there they're obsessed with
these robots that'll you know like these
sex robots and that that they got hair
and all of that stuff right what was it
called again the sloppy toppy robot or
something like that I don't know yeah
I'm just like is that why would you want
to do that over over like a real person
like over I do the old-fashioned is
because the robots can't talk I wouldn't
know the robots was moaning right but
the real war me like you touch it and
ruin it and the the guy was touching her
on touching on her breasts touch it
actually woman no no it was it was it
was it was a robot but but when you
touched it it would go if you touched it
city she'd be go
you touch it over a pain - broken man
might say that in your says I'm doing
dishes stuff no your robot would say
[Laughter]
yeah but bring someone x-ray who's next
sloppy toppy so what you got coming up
you want to promote it
we got like 75,000 listeners now every
week that's right congratulate can we
get a brown applause for that yes and
you know I appreciate you I appreciate
you guys don't have asked so many
questions I forgot them all we're gonna
get you some some kitten blaze merch and
but man get it back to Ric between first
of all you're gonna have this dude this
dude's gonna call me up today hey man
you talking about me joy Coco Diaz told
me what Tyler he was working with him
you know could we all well yeah we all
do you know nothing bad about these guys
they paid yeah they may triple what we
made but they made money they made we
made a lot of money and smart guys like
Rick would do we're doing after parties
they do after party you do Ontario
improv wait with with Rick you know or
even even my man Robert Zapata
you know they got 250 300 people there
on a Wednesday then they got the after
set down the block you don't know right
he totally booked her at that theater
with the TV show the movie theater show
and Hollywood oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I remember that yeah yeah yeah
it was trying to do that yeah you know
hustling you know never saying and and
you know what sometimes that that stuff
you know that we you know sometimes it's
good I mean it was good they were good
they were always good audiences to get
implicated up in front of Joe Diaz was
did a show one time with Rick with
cheering in Modesto somewhere I don't
know where it was and um
he looked to the side and Rick Marty
martini was selling Jody a DVD or in his
comedy album he recorded it another show
and was selling it in front of him
that's take this home with you that's
Rick
that's rigged bro remember all right he
was doing that when he was doing the
bowling alley shows here yeah I'm
recording and I thought you hands - BRR
BRR BRR BRR BRR please don't don't
record my show man I want my [ __ ] out
there man
it's not even funny yeah it's not even
prepared I'm working this out and he
didn't record me but I remember he
recorded other people oh I remember I'm
bowling alley they became part of a
bowling alley comedy scenes me gave me
though you didn't get me huh he try to
get me yeah you'd have to yeah if you
didn't tell him not to yeah yes the time
he would do it he had a camera yeah of
course he had a camera all the time
you're the head of a new the head of the
game though gonna start his own network
yeah what he was and he was he was um he
was great at having first of all yeah
like 20 comics on the show right he was
good at hanging on Hall people yes
that's what I'm saying
Kenny that's what I'm saying you like he
would that was a requirement he was a
requirement you gotta bring you got to
bring people or this Dan the third and
whatnot so that's why they be like 15
comics on the joint you know me and then
then they get to you know the guys like
us later on or whatever I work with uh
remember our Juan Garcia yeah I just did
I just did show him like like three
weeks ago when we whit whit whit whit
Rick I hadn't seen one in forever man
and he wanted forever I'm still the same
size little Kenny they were working with
Rick they were when Rick was harshly
made it really works on the phone he won
a phone call in change is Susie this is
this is I wasn't a mom so he comes to
the show right so you're gonna bring
those how many people ten okay give me
their names
are they what were they 15 people okay
what's your name and he rained out all
these names my mother like 700 names
yeah yeah and another thing he would do
to was you know Rick Rick back then I
think he's more like settle down now but
Rick was out there out and about with
the ladies so he have he'd have all
these ladies coming to the show and you
know he was kind of who's kind of like
flirting with all of them like kind of
romancing on you know some of the you
know just to bring a man huh
you know they're saying that gorditas
would be in the house you know I'm
saying and he would be charming and all
it's a net and then and at the end of
the night you know maybe they think they
gonna hook up with him and he's just
want you to be twenty people that's
right
ain't nothing like a Puerto Rican with
the BMW kept them moving
Rick kept the movement big shout out to
Rick Martinez here's a ring right now
yeah yes
Vegas the last time no Vegas okay I
should I should confuse in my head I
should confuse him and Ricky Cruz but
Ricky Cruz it's a comedian from Miami
and Rick Martinez a Puerto Rican guy
from really from Philly
originally R is rich hey yo you know
what he's into now this is this is fun
Rick or Rick Martinez Martinez he told
me he's into he's flying planes he flies
planes like he showed me pictures and
footage of it I gave him in the cockpit
of a plane yeah yeah man I'm really into
plane I said what like like like why he
just you know he got into it so he flies
he's trying to get certain kind of
licenses or whatever like that I was
like Rick Martinez I just realized
you're not talking about Chris Martinez
are you doing brother you want to close
out the show the Latino Chris we need
you to show me we got power Drita's
coming over Seinfeld talked about big
money brother
that baby what happened to Rick and then
you're saying Vegas and then I'm
thinking no he left to go to Texas with
this girl he fell in love with Chris met
some girl though and fell hard for her
like asked for her dad for her hand in
marriage all official just her hand dude
heard about anybody bring up Rick Marty
no empathy you're right about that
because every latina where or will I
have that one but I do to the girl with
call mm-hmm yeah
that was it that was it but that's you
know what look and and you know once
again whenever when I was alright ever I
see you doing your thing and your
specials on TV and whatnot you know I'm
saying we always feel happy and proud
but you know it's it's the it's the it's
the funny story that's that's this is a
funny part you know like you know I mean
now you know like you're getting you
getting your accolades now as you should
and the podcast was growing and all this
and that and and there's a lot of things
that's a lot easier now I'm sure then
back in the days you know being you
people know you and all this in that but
man sometimes who's funny man you know
those those Dill's dates and corpus that
that at the shitty club and the you know
what I'm saying and the Genki promoter
is another fat guy who's hitting the
horn with his stomach and you know what
I'm saying like you know to meet and
fighting with the clerk's office early
GE you know I'm saying like like that
hey bro I want you to close up this
National Council of La I got you booked
flight to Oakland but you're gonna make
a stop in San Diego alright oh wait oh
you would do um you would do a gig with
with Rudy and um I mean one time I did a
gig with Rudy in like Scottsdale yeah it
was like a bunch of Latin lawyers like
Oh some writers like that right I know
the other show for scholarships yeah
yeah yes right Rudy stuff was always
like aboveboard
you don't mean like legitimate charities
like memory used to do that um that
Christmas joint and that Christmas joint
every I don't know if he still doesn't
always for touch right yeah but yeah
whatever yeah we were all we would all
to perform there i member one year to do
from black eyed peas got up there and he
was he was telling jokes
yeah boo came up they tell jokes and
then you know everybody with you know
that that's that kind of stuff so when
Rudy did something you knew it was you
know you knew it was legit but these are
all the people that you know that kind
of helped us get get going and get
started and you know I'm sure they
appreciated us you know doing our thing
and you know we needed you know I needed
the time at the time you know Sunday
they'd be like eight nobody remembers me
no more crying on Facebook they went
price is yeah you know I could choose do
stand-up comedy you know maybe you
should've stopped you know get away from
me I saw every once in a while
mmm hit up another room yo remember
remember he used to have four Thursday
nights commerce that place you'd be back
big or little billboard yeah a place was
funky-fresh Godfather years on yeah Brad
Carrie to show up yes like you ha yeah a
place was he had that place she was that
every time I Drive by the place and I'm
just like never saw more than a hundred
little Jaguar parked outside huh yeah oh
yeah you should always see the Jaguar
outside the house I used to coming up -
Rudy I said really
no offense but I wanna [ __ ] your car
okay he still has the boy who stole it
from Band Aids big shout out shout out
to Rudy well all the promoters what you
got coming up okay as I mentioned we got
the we got the big we got the big ship
coming up ship hop look it up look it up
ship hop it's under the I love the 90s
tour banner that'll be great
you know I actually I'll be in town for
the next for the next few weeks I think
you know in the run-up to Christmas so
I'm gonna try to jump up I've been on
the road so much I'm gonna try to jump
up around town maybe like the Laugh
Factory improv yeah yeah scatter stone
or I love Sarah Sarah mellow Sarah
laughs I chose now yeah yeah yes that
was my homegirl man we look we love
Sarah yeah yeah you can follow me at kid
from kid and play on Instagram and
Twitter and your stuff you can check us
out at real kid in blazed an Instagram
yeah and and we you know we're gonna
start to make a make it available we're
trying to get ready for this you know
for the changes that are that a
forthcoming in January's and try to make
the make our string you know more
available down here I mean we actually
out of Bakersfield you know growing out
of Bakersfield and we got them in a few
spots down here in LA but you know we're
always trying to do and and and get
better with it and go wider so remember
kidding blaze and we're in bed mobility
be kidding cookies we got well we got we
got deals with highway 99 got a couple
of other ones that would that we mess
with and the growhouse is up there as
well so we got a cool grower by the name
of Harry blaze he's like one of them
he's like
right but he's like he's like all into
the science we you know luckily he
reminds me of like who's the guy from
Back to the Future like the guy yeah the
guy was making the car you know I mean
like he's just all into that he knows
everything scientifically you know about
about weed so we just just kind of let
him we just kind of let him um you know
do this thing and and and he and he came
out with it with a great strain
ours is a hybrid it's uh it's Girl Scout
cookies with the Snowman og so it's a
nice hybrid what's up fool yeah man big
you're on the hot box would be real I
sure was me I almost died dude know that
like it's a real hard box there's no you
know that smokers it's getting now it's
all endure we came down there with it
with a gang of our strain of kidding
cookies and they rolled up a can't keeps
a real man there's a few people that
show up to weed shows with their own
weed there's three people now there's
kid from kiddin play Joe Diaz and me
every time I've been invited to a weed
show I would bring weed yeah cuz I know
this [ __ ] might not be that good yeah
not only hang and you want him to like
your suit yeah about your [ __ ] so we had
we bought a stupid-ass jar gave gave
that to be real he must have rolled up
about ten blunts we got in we got in the
car and I think I was in there for about
a half an hour cuz he and I go way way
way back and we like we had a lot to
talk about and whatnot and I appreciated
him you know trying to give my company
exposure because we you know we're all
trying to follow his blueprint I mean
he's the man when it comes to when it
comes to that that Fool has lightsaber
roaches bro yeah he's got so yeah so he
that we had the blunts with the with the
with the tips on him and all this and
that and man I do he knocked my he
knocked my dick in the dirt dude I was
so [ __ ] faded but but it was great it
was a great great exposure and a big
shot to him for helping us out shut up
to be real TV he was only the other so
too with the green screw yeah that'd be
real TV and and the guy is on we don't
smoke the same shaky was so cool Felipe
Esparza right here Lisa
Oh Daniel as far as I Rodrigo Torres
we got Aaron over
they're looking for a house shout out to
him always here right now how's it feel
how does it feel to be able to live any
way you want to feels good
what's so fool kidding play right here
Chris read how you doing I hear him
please
hey great to be here oh yeah let's get
hot where's my sample